alright let's get started so we can get
to the closing keynote Sand sessions
this is from developer to manager how to
survive the obligatory introduction as
advised by the Drupal Association my
name is Brian Thompson I'm the director
of web engineering at a company called
my group technologies headquartered in
Baltimore Maryland just down the street
from Fort McHenry on the complete
opposite side of the United States I've
been working with web technology since
2006 most importantly I am a developer
who now carries a manager title where I
guess I did a good enough job at
managing that they actually gave me a
director title so it's like twice the
managership you can find me on twitter
so if afterwards you have questions and
you're not sure how to get them to me
you can tweet them at me or you can find
me on drupal.org or stop me in the
hallway or find me a trivia night or
anywhere else with Baker outdoorsman
tech nerd apparently a manager as well
so let's play out a scenario for
everybody but I show of hands how many
people in the room are developers would
call themselves developer very good the
large majority how many people by a show
of hands are developers in managerial
roles another good portion probably 75
80 percent or so wonderful this talk is
both for those people who raise their
hands and those who didn't so I'm glad
you're here so imagine this Monday
morning comes around
you've got your coffee and your drupal
syberia cup and you get called into your
boss's office and you're like oh boy
what's on the docket for this week and
then the mario music plays and you get
this plus one level up and you find out
that you've been promoted to manager
which is great because all developers
are naturally good at managing people if
they're good at writing code right or
maybe it happens a different way if
you're like me you don't get called into
your boss's office instead you get
called into a chars office on Monday
morning that's always an exciting way to
start
yeah really got the blood going didn't
need coffee that day and they tell you
oh we're writing job descriptions for
every position I'm like great I'll work
with my fellow co developers and we'll
all come up with a job description like
no we want you to write a managerial job
description I'm like why they're like
because it's yours I'm like oh so that's
how I find out I'm promoted great so
what do you do this happens to me
happens to many of you what do we go
about doing and so as I sit back to sort
of boil things down I always do what I
try and do when I'm solving a technical
problem the developer side of me comes
out and I want to start simple and I
want to keep things as simple as I
possibly can while keeping things
working in my developer mind about how I
write code with loops and conditions and
Drupal hooks and services and twig and
everything else and so naturally as I'm
thinking through all of the code that I
was about to write that day that I'm not
going to my mind wandered to the
vacation I had upcoming where I was
planning on going whitewater rafting as
I was thinking about it I realized that
being a manager being a developer who's
been promoted into a managerial position
is just like going whitewater rafting by
show of hands how many people have been
whitewater rafting before probably about
60% or so 70% wonderful and right now
you're all looking at me going what does
paddling a boat down a river as we go up
and down have to do with being a manager
that's good
I'll show you it also gives me an
opportunity to find pictures of
whitewater rafting and plan my future
wait what a rafting trip so whenever you
go whitewater rafting what's the first
thing that they always do with you
before you even get close to the water
they sit you on this boat one land and
they're like this is how you work the
boat and you're looking at them going
I'm sorry
where's the water but the most important
all a part of all of that is that
they're telling you a few key pieces of
information and they're giving you
things namely equipment so the first
step when you're trying to simplify
being a manager previously a developer
is to make sure you use proper equipment
as a developer we would be using our
code
editor maybe phpstorm or one of the
other editors out there Adam sublime
text etc when we go whitewater rafting
we also get the proper equipment
personal flotation devices when I was
going whitewater rafting the first time
I was like great I get a lifejacket
they're like no it's not a lifejacket
I'm like is a lifejacket it buckles
around me it keeps me above water
they're like right that's a personal
flotation device it's not going to save
your life it's just going to keep your
head above water when you go in a
manager position you have to figure out
what your personal flotation device is
in my case and what I would recommend to
many of you is that it's actually
another person as a manager you're about
to find out a number of different things
that you didn't actually know is
happening you're gonna be given
information that you didn't really care
about as a developer budgets numbers
managing people States of projects how
other teams are doing and all of that's
going to come in and try and push you
downward you need a personal flotation
device my recommendation is to find
somebody else who you can vent to and
you can offload in that them hold you up
next piece they give you when you go
whitewater rafting is a helmet that's
for your safety it will try and save
your life most of the time it's
successful as a manager you need to find
your helmet and what's going to protect
your head maybe that's your favorite
pair of headphones maybe that's in my
case Reese's Peanut Butter Easter eggs
which are luckily in season but
something to sort of keep my head in
good shape as I'm going through things
and keeping me focused last piece of
equipment they normally give you
individually is a paddle sometimes they
give you extra paddles because they know
you'll lose them it's happened before
in this case paddles equate to the what
you actually use the physical tools as a
manager so test tracking software I'm
not here to tell you that juror is
better than asana which is better than
Trello which is better than the other
new product out there but as a manager
you're about to have a ton of
information come flowing into you and
you're gonna have a bunch of requests to
actually do something
some of which might be important and
some of which might not generally the
requests come in faster than you can
complete the requests which is
unfortunate but presents good job
security for the most part and so what I
recommend is you go out there and you
find yourself a piece of task tracking
software would I like to use what a
number of my co-workers like to use as
they go out and they set out a set up a
Trello board it's free and they just put
in what they need to do for the course
of the week starts on Monday they keep
adding things as things come in by the
end of the week hopefully everything is
in the done column or we know what we're
rolling into future weeks makes it super
easy with the mobile app to be able to
take and as you receive those requests
JIRA works much the same way you set it
up as a Kanban style project find
yourself some task tracking software
that's out there you'll also find that
this helps you keep track of what the
rest of your team is doing because
hopefully you're using some sort of task
tracking software for software
development keeping track of tickets via
JIRA
Trello etc etc in addition to having
test tracking software as part of your
paddle tool I also put together an
escalation playbook what I recommend to
all managers is that you take the time
now to sit down and think about what
you're going to do when things go
sideways because they will guaranteed
and if you have written down the process
you're going to follow that you can
reference yourself it's going to be much
easier for you to be able to handle that
scenario the emergency happens people
are mad your brain starts moving a
million miles a minute and you forget
what your process actually is you get
caught up in the moment having this
written down either digitally on your
laptop want a small piece of paper maybe
in your desk drawer under your keyboard
alongside your passwords good to know
you're all still awake
other things to keep in mind figuring
out spreadsheets you will become a
master of spreadsheets functions and
spreadsheets in all the different
formula tools will be your friend where
are you going to store your files as a
manager you might now be handling new
applicants to your company which means
you're receiving resumes where do all of
them live
maybe you we review it once you want to
review it again two years from now
because maybe you're looking for
somebody to fill that role hopefully you
can find that document and you've
organized it in a way that lets you find
it mine is a combination of my Mac plus
Google Drive plus iCloud Drive plus a
USB thumb drive it's not very organized
it's an area I'm working one but I know
I have a problem and one area that you
often don't think about as a manager I
didn't think about until it came back to
you me was HR software now you're all
looking at me going Brian we're
developers that's HR they're the ones
who called you into your office to tell
you to write a job description in the
first place what do we want to do with
HR software as a manager you're going to
find yourself doing these wonderful
things called performance reviews where
you have to track how well people on
your team are not doing regardless of
how you go about doing them and your HR
software it could be as simple as a
Google Drive folder which is how mine
started out being able to keep track of
those sorts of HRE things in the
performance reviews that your team is
doing or that you're doing for your team
and you can reference them every six
months twelve months three months
however frequently you're doing those
reviews will be beneficial to you so
find proper equipment now that we've got
our equipment we can find ourselves out
on the river getting ready all these
people have their paddle in the air if
you go away what a rafting they tell you
don't put your paddle in the air luckily
there are photos of people doing it
though so we have this experience and
what those people are doing and it's not
actually great for them besides the guy
in the back who has the black paddle
sticking out the side of the boat is
going with the flow everybody likes to
go with the flow everybody likes to keep
things easy
I don't want to rock the boat all right
to use another phrase I just want to
have everything go along well when
you're whitewater rafting and they tell
you don't put your paddles up in the air
and you can't go with the flow you have
to either go faster than the water or
you have to go slower than the water if
you're going away water rafting and
you're going at the same speed as the
water you have a problem because that
means the water is now in control if
you're moving faster than the water
you're in control of your boat if you're
moving slower than the water you're in
control of your boat same thing applies
to managers as we go along be it for the
people in your team or the clients that
you're working with either go faster
than your projects or people or more
commonly let your team do what they do
best and be great and you go slightly
slower but if you go at the same speed
as your teammates and your clients
you're gonna let them be in control and
as a manager you need to stay in control
even though it's a team effort as you
move along so keep your paddle in the
water keep using your tools move faster
move slower than your projects and your
teammates now even as we go with the
flow as we're going down this proverbial
river here sometimes you end up looking
like this you'll notice that the water
is flowing towards the bottom of the
screen the boat is actually pointed to
the left of the screen and everybody has
their eyes focused off the left-hand
side of the boat meaning they're about
to go into that little Rapids they're
sideways when you go right what a
rafting for the first time or with
people who don't go very often
normally this incites panic and they get
super concerned about the fact that
they're about to go through this set of
Rapids sideways and believe they need to
hit things head-on they need to go to
the right direction as a manager as
you're working on projects and working
with your team being able to go the
right direction in a forward direction
the way you're looking is great
I don't know about all of you but
oftentimes when I'm managing projects or
people even though we're moving
downriver we're not always pointed with
the front going directly that way
backwards is actually quite common
sometimes we finished projects by going
backwards and we get there and it's okay
most commonly though sideways is
normally how we go through things think
about the projects you're working on the
teams you're working with is everything
perfectly smooth do you have no problems
if you do that's great that means you're
going down facing forward perfectly
aligned downriver most commonly though
you're probably getting to the end by
going slightly sideways or slightly
off-kilter and that's okay
because when you think about whitewater
rafting when 90 plus percent in the room
raised their hand here to say they had
been before the good news is you're all
still alive so even though you went
through those Rapids potentially
sideways or maybe even backwards you're
still here and you made it through it
but always keep your eye on the prize
and look in the direction that you want
to go so even if you're going into
things a little shakey sideways not
positioned as well as you want to be
keep looking towards where you want to
end up this picture is about practically
underwater they're going through some
big rapids they're about to experience
what in whitewater rafting I call a bump
because they're about to hit that rock
as a manager you can't be afraid to bump
now when you go away water rafting and
the rock is coming up one of the things
that they will tell you to do is
everybody run towards the rock you're
about to hit don't go away from it go
towards it I've watched people as boats
go sideways into a rock the people on
the rock side gets scared and they jump
to the other side away from the rock and
then the rock picks the boat up and
flips it upside down that's not good so
as a manager when you're facing a
problem
lean into it get your team tackling it
head one right in front of it don't run
away from it
this lets you bump off and continue down
smoothly and be able to sort of stick
all your paddles back up in the air
again and high-five each other with your
paddles which is a very whitewater
rafting thing to do don't be afraid to
pump alright now as a manager you're in
this whitewater rafting together we've
got our equipment we bumped we've
accepted the fact that in the case of
this Rapids we're gonna hit it straight
on but we might not always be you're in
the back of the boat back of the boat is
always the guide that's you the manager
you have to give direction giving
direction is one of the hardest things
to do how many people have been
whitewater rafting before and even
though they were told not to paddle they
still put their paddle in the water
right a number of us it's just second
nature because we're panicking that
we're not going straight on so we got to
spin ourselves back and as the person at
the front of the boat I of course know
what's going on and will position my
selves accordingly but as the manager
you have to be willing to give direction
and tell people to take their paddles
out sometimes when you're managing or
guiding a weight water rafting boat only
certain people need to paddle how many
people have been whitewater rafting
before where the guide has told only the
left side of the boat to paddle okay
well everybody who who went way to
rafting has said yes sometimes we just
paddle on the left side sometimes we
just paddle on the right side as a
manager you have to understand when to
push your people and when to let them
rest just a little bit to get yourself
going back in the right direction or
keep yourself moving faster than the
water so okay is a manager to let some
people take the easy road and some
people take the slightly harder road if
we end up at the best space in the end
because ultimately we're figuring out
when to rest our people so that we can
have them with us for the long haul if
we don't do that let me get into one of
my favorite pictures in all of
whitewater rafting which is on the next
slide
this is a picture down in the bottom
it's this picture if you're going away
water rafting and your feet are up in
the air that's even worse than having
your paddles up in the air it means
you're about to get very very wet and
you're about to evacuate the boat you'll
notice that a paddle sticking up in the
air in two feet sticking up in the air
means things have gone drastically wrong
this means you no longer have your
paddle which means you no longer have
your tools these people are probably
having fun though once they get back in
the boat so you have to deal with
adversity as a manager when your boat
flips over things are problematic they
won't always go well in fact I can
probably count a number of times in my
own managerial career where they most
definitely did not go well times where
that code fix that tested fine in
staging and test and development and on
my local machine and on my developers
local machine all looked great and then
I ran it in the production environments
and I wiped out a database of a hundred
thousand products that was didn't go
well the boat was upside down I had lost
my paddle in my feet were in the air
luckily I had my personal flotation
device to bring me back up that night
always make sure you bounce back up as a
manager you are the one in control if
you bounce back up everybody else when
your team will bounce back up now when
you go whitewater rafting and you do
fall out of the boat one of the
important things that they tell you is
to keep your feet pointed in the
direction that you're going you don't go
down the river headfirst even if you're
wearing a helmet that's kind of
dangerous try and go feet first so worst
case you just break a leg
as you're dealing with adversity always
make sure that you keep your feet
pointed downriver in the direction you
want to go keep yourself focused in that
direction even if you're not in the
comfort of the boat and also remember
that you can't always get back to the
comfort of the raft right away when
things go wrong has managers we like to
fix them as quickly as we can somebody
comes to me with a problem they say
Brian got a problem okay
what the license for my sublime text has
expired okay
I'm using Adam in the meantime great do
I need to get you back in the sublime
text raft right away
no on the flip side there are times
where you need to get back in the raft
as quickly as you can as you go through
those classics Rapids Brian I have a
problem yes I just wiped out the
customers database with a hundred
thousand products let's get back in the
raft as quickly as we possibly can but
most importantly as a manager there's
one thing you have to keep in mind and
that's to always have a positive
attitude even when there's water coming
over the front of the boat and be that
smiling and holding your hands up in the
air the person near the top right we're
sticking your tongue out for a
photograph or just smiling which is
normally the best thing you can do as a
manager you're a positive attitude will
impact all of those around you and cause
them to have a positive attitude as well
at this point I'll open the floor up for
questions there's a microphone that the
Drupal Association would like it if you
used
thank you
[Applause]
there are no questions the Drupal
Association also asked me to remind you
that tomorrow are the contribution
sprints they are happening on this floor
over that way room 602 606 and 6a and if
you liked my session please do go rate
it online tell us what you liked the
Drupal Association the program committee
uses that in subsequent years to help
refine the program to put on a better
con